non-minimalists
all right megan wants to know how do you
balance staying informed with spending
time in the moment
is there a secret algorithm to seeing
only the highlights
and the funny stuff so jess i did
try to separate this a little bit
earlier but like you have personal
accounts as well you're at jess breathes
on on all the
relevant social media platforms myspace
and tumblr wherever else she is
um so let's talk about balance
right because you do have social media
accounts on your phone
out of necessity here um but
how do you find balance screenless
saturdays yeah um i
i find balance because what i'm looking
for with screenless saturdays what is it
it is the space between stimuli and
response and i have a full 24 hours
every single week
to um have a deeper relationship with
that space
and recognize the value in it but also
confront myself because i feel like
that's really what we're looking to do
here
is confront ourselves and we're looking
for like why am i searching for the
phone
and i think that so often we search for
it but then we don't
we're not really paying attention to the
fact that there's something that's
that's deeper going on so i really feel
that
the value is looking inward and
stopping for a moment and placing up
those boundaries parenting yourself i
i just treated you because last night
you were like i gotta i'm getting riled
up i gotta go to bed i'm white like i
gotta wind down oh yeah
that's right the value of parenting
yourself and
and looking at yourself because really
like you know
children when i see a child crying in
the store i can like relate
i'm like i kind of look at them and i'm
like yeah you know what i kind of feel
that way sometimes
so um so i so i think that we all have
like that person inside of us so i think
if we recognize that and we're aware of
the fact that that person is inside of
us
then we can um both be compassionate for
ourselves and draw effective boundaries
yeah i got some of the pithy for you and
maybe we can talk about it just briefly
here but
when she's asking how do you balance
staying in the form of spending time
in the moment is there a secret
algorithm
to only the highlights and yes find out
on our maximal episode what that secret
algorithm is
um so so here's my pithy answer when
everything's important
nothing's important and what i mean by
that
is we call a twitter stream for a reason
or a social media stream
right imagine trying to consume every
drop of water in a river
or imagine just trying to touch every
drop of water in a river
you can't now if someone like me who has
ocd i'm a completeist i would love i
try to catch up on things but i've i've
also surrendered and so
i think the word we're looking for here
is
surrender i think we have to surrender
to the fact that
we're missing out and it's okay in fact
the fear of missing out is the problem
not the missing out the missing out is
not a
problem at all miss out but miss out on
the right thing so you don't miss out
on the actually the things that are
actually important
yeah my pithy answer is this there is no
secret algorithm for discipline
and i wish it was as simple as you know
downloading an app and although an app
called discipline sounds like there's
something there
patent-pending but yeah these are things
that we have in our lives and
in the social dilemma it talks about how
this technology is you know growing way
faster than the way we're able to evolve
in fact we haven't involved at all since
this technology so
we have to come up with ways to handle
this technology ourselves and it takes a
lot of discipline
yeah yes it does all right well we've
got some listener tips some really great
listening tips today
also an added value segment you don't
want to miss out on unless
well but you don't have fear of missing
out you can miss out on it if you want
right
yeah uh but we do have a bunch more
surprise questions a bunch more surprise
questions this week
here are some of them what are two
things you can do right now to improve
your relationship with your smartphone
do smartphones make us dumb we've got an
article about that also what's the best
way to ditch your smartphone if that's
something you're trying to do
what are the three biggest problems with
the documentary the social dilemma
how do you build a screen time budget
and what's the best
digital declutter experiment what are
the consequences of ryan
unfollowing everyone on social media i
can't wait to answer that one
uh if you had to use only one social
media platform what should it be
i'm gonna be talking to jess about that
also is social media
essential to run a business that's a
good one too plus a million more
questions for jessica
and the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that subscribe to our maximal
episodes on the minimalist private
podcast it's a completely separate
podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income
because we don't believe in ads by the
way if you're not a private podcast
subscriber
you're literally missing out on
two-thirds of
what we create so just be aware of that
you can try it out just for a week or a
few weeks or a month
what we're trying to do is add immense
value to your life in fact i have a
quote here
from a new patreon supporter she says oh
my god i
just pasted this in from from patreon oh
my god these episodes
absolutely blew my mind i just had to
pause and come here to write this
comment
this private episode is all together on
a different level compared to the public
one
great work i love it the reason being is
and jess tell me about this
our our maximal episodes ryan and i know
they're different but how are they
different to you
i think they're different to me in the
sense that you seem like you can be more
free there
and i i think obviously if you have
somebody that's paying for your work i
think that
if you look at it that's really the
issue with social media is there
i think we're if if we were if we had
um advertisers then
our audience would be the product yeah
and i think that that's really when
we're talking about the fact that
advertisements suck and we don't have
advertisements on the podcast that's why
is because we want to be the
one group of individuals that say you
are not a product
that you are something more than that
yeah and by the way
what we have to do is continue to add
value to you and the places that
advertise don't have to necessarily add
value
they just need to get your eyeballs onto
their service
because you are the product as you
alluded to